درجات حراره عاليه تحتفظ بها الطرق
السعوديه صيفا قد تصل الى 60 درجه مئويه
ما دفع المختبر المركزي لفحص الطرق في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
لفحص الطرق ايضا وقد نفد اكثر من 530
مراجعه واعتماد للخلطات التصميميه المنفذه
للطرق العامه بالاضافه الى اجراء 260 فحصا
لمواد الانشاء المعنيه لخلطات الطرق
ويستعد المختبر ايضا لتنفيذ اختبار خفض
درجات الحراره العاليه التي تتعرض لها
كافه الطرق داخل السعوديه
ينضمينها نصفيان من المختبر المركزي لفحص
الطرق في السعوديه حياك الله هاني عرفنا
اكثر على هذا المختبر
نعم اهلا بك يا خالد واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه اليوم كاميرا العربيه تتواجد في
المركز او مختبر مركزي وهو يعتبر الوحيد
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط هذا المختبر الذي
يتبع هيئه الطرق في السعوديه وتم ايضا
تنفيذه من اجل حمايه وايضا معرفه جوده
الطرق وكذلك ايضا اجراء اختبارات عديده
للطرق في السعوديه خاصه في ظل ايضا ارتفاع
في درجات حرارات حراره الطرق وكذلك في بعض
ايضا عمليات الصيانه وايضا بعض قله جوده
هذه الطرق فاليوم هذا المختبر يعتبر
ومختبر يتم في التجارب قبل تنفيذها على
ارض الواقع عموما معي في مدير اداره
الجوده في هيئه الطرق المهندس عباس
الحازمي مرحبا بك مهندس عباس ولنقترب
قليلا وقبل ان نبدا طبعا اليوم كاميرا
العربيه تتواجد في مختبرين منفصلين
ومختلفين واحد هنا في هذا المختبر الذي
نتواجد فيه والمختبر الاخر من الكاميرا
الاخرى وهي ايضا يتواجد ويشاهد فيها
الكوادر البشريه التي تعمل على اختبار
جوده نوعيه وخامه في الطرق دعنا اول شيء
نتكلم اليوم لهذا اليوم وجد هذا المختبر
ليش تم تنفيذه من قبل الحياه الطرق حياك
الله استاذ هاني والعربيه في مركز ابحاث
الطرق واختبارات الرصد المتعجل ايضا
والمختبر المركزي التابعين للهيئه العامه
للطرق
الصراحه مركز الابحاث والمختبر المركزي من
المنشات المتطوره والفريده في الشرق
الاوسط من نوعها لا يوجد لها مثيل في
منطقه الخليج والشرق الوسط ولله الحمد
مهتمه المنشات بالدراسات البحثيه في كل ما
هو جديد في مجال مواد الطرق واساليب
التنفيذ
واجراء ضبط الجوده
يعني مهندس ما عباس خلينا نتكلم لك اياه
بشكل واضح اليوم في بعض المواطنين في بعض
في مناطق مختلفه يشتكون من ردات الطرق
وكذلك في بعض المناطق خاصه التي فيها
ارتفاعها في درجه حراره يشتكون ارتفاع
درجات الحراره العاليه مقارنه ببعض الدول
هل هذا المختبر سوف يفي بهذا الامر ما
الذي قمتم به طبعا مثل هذه المشاكل ومثل
هذه الدراسات وجدت هذه المنشات ولله الحمد
لدينا العديد من الدراسات في تقام في هذا
المركز في المختبر المركزي منها كما ذكرت
تبريد الاسطح الاسفلتيه كما هو معروف احنا
في منطقه حاره يعني كان الان تقريبا درجات
الحراره تصل 60 كم
العرصه الاسفلتيه توصل درجات الحراره الى
75 واكثر في الصيف وايضا هي من الارصفه
المخزنه للحراره اثناء النهار وتبثه في
الليل
الدراسه عملت على انه نحاول انه نعكس اشعه
الشمس وبالتالي يقل تخزين الارصفه
الاسفلتيه لاشعه الشمس للحراره تتوقع راح
تصل درجه الحراره
التجارب يعني والله حاليا حتى الان
النتائج الحمد لله مشجعه في انخفاض يصل
الى 15 درجه ما بين الاسفلت وما بين
القطاع المطلبي بالدهانات والحمد لله
نعم تم تجربتها ولله الحمد في مدينه
الرياض
نعم موجود الان
في هي استهدفت اماكن نشاط بشري وحركه
السيارات
اخترنا الصراحه من اسوا الاماكن او اسوا
الظروف للمنتجات اللي هو حراج ساحه حراج
الشفاء بالسيارات في مدينه الرياض
نعم ومضى على التجربه الحمد لله الى ثلاثه
اشهر تقريبا
نعمل جنبا لجنب مع الشركات الوطنيه لتحسين
المنتجات اذا ظهرت عندنا بعض الملاحظات
البسيطه في تحسين وهمم
يعني وضع المقاول اليوم اللي ينفذ هذه
الطرق
كيف يتم تقييمه يعني في بعض المقاولين
اليوم نشاهد يتوقع لبعض انه والله هيئه
الطرق ليس لديها رقابه على هؤلاء
المقاولين لا ابشركم لله الحمد هيئه الطرق
تعمل بكل جد لدينا على جميع الاصعده لدينا
زي ما ذكرنا مختبر يهتم بالجوده لدينا
فريق فني متكامل لدينا جولات تفتيشيه
تسارع تاج في نعم والحمد لله يعني في
انخفاض كبير للملاحظات في الطرق ايضا
يقابله ارتفاع جيد في مؤشر الجوده ولله
الحمد
عندنا يعني ارقام مبشره للجوالات
التفتيشيه يعني وصلنا حول 1800 جوله بمعدل
70 جوله في الشهر والجولات هذه نتائجها
الجولات نتائجها انها يعني قللت من
الملاحظات الكثيره حسنت في اساليب الانتاج
نستبعد بعض المعدات الغير صالحه للعمل او
غير مطابقه للمواصفات وحدات الانتاجيه
ايضا نراق بها ونشوف ادائها
طيب مهندس عباس يعني لو نقترب قليلا وايضا
مشاهدي قناه العربيه اليوم تتكلمون عن هذا
اختبار الاحد التجارب تم فيه اعاده تدوير
صحيح صحيح هذا المقاطع المقاطع هذه اضيف
لها في الخلطه الاسفلتيه كاول مره على
مستوى العالم
مواد ناتج مخلفات البناء والهدم وتعرف هذه
ضررها على البيئه كبير فاحنا ان شاء الله
الدراسه دي تساعد في
رفع كفاءه وايضا في المحافظه على البيئه
واستدامه المواد والمصادر مهندس عباس اذا
كان هذا حديث مهندس عباس الحازمي مدير
الجوده في هيئه الطرق واليوم كنا نتابع
ايضا اول مره كاميرا العربيه ترصد من خلال
المختبرين منفصلين وعبر كاميرتين وايضا من
كاميرات العربيه ترصد مختبرين منفصلين في
منطقتين مختلفتين المركز الذي يعتبر
الوحيد في الشرق الاوسط لاختبار جوده
وكذلك كماليه الطرق في السعوديه
شكرا جزيلا لك انا الصيام من المقتبل
المركزي لفحص الطرق في الرياض لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات